lori garrett
um
author of the coming plague right from a
long time ago
um who has not um
done a brilliant job throughout this
quote tweets
the new silent majority the fully vaxxed
of an atlantic article
um
which let's see i didn't pull it up for
the silent this is uh a atlantic article
published a few days ago
the silent vaccinated impatient majority
as patients with epidemic wanes leaders
and widely vaccinated democracies are
deploying a new political strategy
and it
proceeds to explain
how
those who are vaccinated just fed up
with those of us who aren't and it's our
fault well they're continuing the
pandemic of the unvaccinate even
now i mean this is what is the 21st the
22nd even now um it's like four or five
days ago
even now yeah even now
well but when the the efficacy of these
things is so
clearly
through the floor
right and you're gonna get on your high
horse
about being impatient with those of us
who resisted your crap treatment
well it's it's you know
dog whistle is an overused term but it's
a dog whistle for people who were
gullible enough to fall for that line in
the first place and the point is you
know
i at least have some sympathy for people
who didn't know what to do didn't know
who to listen to
and
you know said well
there
these people
who have all of the things that are
supposed to indicate that they are
scientifically credible are telling me
that they've looked at the evidence
they've looked at the safety they've
looked at the efficacy and that i should
get this thing right yeah but are you
sympathetic to people who are still now
this week saying well i did everything
right and i'm just really fed up with
the people who didn't because it's their
fault look i'm sympathetic with anybody
who didn't have the tools to make sense
of it that's not sympathetic with people
who did have the tools and decided not
to use them well but i guess
and this again it's really hard to
discriminate between can't and won't
but part of what i am
wrestling with at the moment is
the reveal
that so many people among the so-called
intelligentsia the chattering classes of
the coasts
either cannot or will not engage in what
for us as people who think
scientifically every day of our lives by
second nature doing analysis
and just
basic hypothesis generation and an
attempt to look into the actual data
insofar as it's been available
there's been almost none of that is it a
can't or it won't i don't know well but
i mean this went down
uh through the careful use of incentives
yeah right and the whole point the whole
reason
that
the
uh that the experience was from our side
what it was had to do with the fact that
what was really being said to people
is
look at them
there but for the grace of god go you
now the way that you stay out of that
position is you don't explore in this
way to the extent that somebody put very
frightening stuff in the path of those
who might otherwise have been open to an
analysis
you know
i don't respect
not thinking because somebody is trying
to scare you away from thinking but i
understand it right right right and
depending upon who you are you know a
lot of people were isolated they did not
know that's true who was making sense
and
you know it's not simple yep right
um so okay i've i've taken the atlantic
to task a lot um over the last
year or two in part because i'm super
disappointed in it because it was um it
was it was one of my first literary
loves
and i was treated well by it early on
and um and this zachary if you would
show this this is the article i just
showed the silent vaccinated patient
majority well i'm old enough to remember
when the atlantic was publishing
articles like this 2010 did pfizer bribe
its way out of criminal charges in
nigeria wikileaks cables shed new light
into one of big pharma's darkest hours
and i'm just going to read the date on
that 2010.
uh just read the first paragraph here on
day 12 of wikileaks release of u.s state
department cables the daily drip drip
drip of diplomatic secrets implicated
the pharmaceutical industry the company
was pfizer the country was nigeria and
the context was the long-simmering
still-bitter aftermath of the drug drug
of the drug giant's quick and dirty 1996
trials of an experimental antibiotic for
children during a devastating meningitis
outbreak a truly chilling cautionary
tale of industry-funded clinical trials
in the developing world this event is
recalled in the west mainly as
inspiration for john le carre's evil
pharma thriller the constant gardener
so the constant gardener is one of the
two films that we watched this week zach
if i may have my screen back thank you
which
uh is
extraordinary and and and you know also
won all sorts of awards for its sort of
artistic and and narrative skill um
it's a 2005 film based on the 2001 john
le carre novel the same name um and
interestingly so that atlantic article
suggests that is understood and there is
a lot of stuff that suggests that lacari
really was loosely basing this on
on what happened with pfizer in nigeria
but at the end of the film
there is a quote from le carre that said
that reads
nobody in this story and no outfitter
corporation thank god is based upon an
actual person or outfit in the real
world
but i can tell you this
as my journey through the pharmaceutical
jungle progressed i came to realize that
by comparison with the reality my story
was as tame as a holiday postcard
i recommend this movie
i recommend this movie highly and i also
recommend the movie you watched last
night which we had seen before but we
watched with our boys for the first time
which is dallas buyers club
a 213 a 2013 movie um so-called
biographical drama
based on the real life story of ron
woodruff um
story takes place in the mid to late
1980s during the aids crisis
and at the end of the movie the quote
there interesting about both of these
movies there are quotes at the end that
you don't typically see
the likes of at the end of movies at the
end of this movie
we have aids is not over
access to treatment could save many more
lives
and
dallas buyers club doesn't have anything
to do with africa but there's a there's
a common theme here in terms of
what kind of medical
capers have actually happened in africa
and who is actually being harmed
and
what the people who are doing the harm
sound like when they talk about what
they're doing there and it's almost
always exactly the opposite of what
they're actually doing
i think this
is a piece of the puzzle here that we
are never
going to have an easy time conveying
which is that there is a process
in normal business there is a
um
a positive feedback
right where
i've used the example of you know if
you're going to to design the interior
of a car
you're going to make decisions that are
going to result in certain people dying
right because if you were to design a
car in which you made every decision
such that you know it had no downsides
the car would be impossibly expensive
and then possibly gas guzzling and so
you know there are trade-offs
but the point is once you are in the
world of trade-offs where the point is
your decisions have the result and
result in somebody's
death here and there and you start
getting comfortable with that as part of
the process there's no end to it and so
pharmaceutical companies run trials
these trials involve people dying from
medications because you need to know how
safe the thing is and obviously a
medication could be wonderfully valuable
and have a certain amount of
harm in the form of people dying who
have particular predispositions or
whatever right so the point is there's a
there's a utilitarian metric
by which you get an allowance
for for doing terrible things to people
and the point is once you get
comfortable with that
as these films obviously reveal
um you know one in the case of an
african trial and the other in the case
of
um the absurd use of azt earlier in the
in the aids and the refusal of fda to
allow any other points of treatment
right a familiar pattern but the point
is once
pharma or any other industry gets used
to the carnage that results from
business as usual the point is then it
becomes a question of scale
yeah right and that's what we saw here
is a brand new scale of something that
actually isn't remarkable for pharma it
happens all the time it just this time
it involved all of us
yeah this this went full global um
typically they have restricted
themselves to a continent
right but
but my point is
all of the
things that people are having a hard
time believing actually could possibly
have happened i mean what protected the
pharma effort here was that it was
impossible to believe that people would
do this to other humans and that's what
kind of lie was it
right was it noble
what it was was business as usual at a
scale that has never been seen at an
absolutely unprecedented scale right and
that is actually a story that we need to
wrap our minds around right that this is
happening all the time with other
diseases and other drugs and
um you know often far enough out of your
view that it seems very very remote
right
but
uh
anyway
the scale caught us off guard and
hopefully it's woken us up
[Music]
you